[Music]
foreign
Thousand Days China's borders have been
closed to the world and its population
has suffered through lockdowns
China's zero covert policy XI jinping's
response to the virus mostly kept the
pandemic at Bay saving lives but by the
end it had become a waking nightmare for
many residents attempting to cut metal
chains trying to break free from
lockdown in an eastern district of the
city officers were forcing people out of
their rented apartments that policy was
scrapped in early December since then
covid-19 has ravaged the population this
Shanghai hospital is one of the best in
the country and it's overwhelmed by the
current surge in covert cases right now
in China things look Grim tens of
millions of people are catching the
virus hospitals are overwhelmed more
than a million people might die as a
result of this latest outbreak see
sudden policy reversal will have deadly
consequences for the people of China but
as he opens the country for business
with the rest of the world his actions
will have a profound Global impact
China's reopening will be 2023's biggest
economic event I'm Rachel scharnberg The
Economist business Affairs editor and
here are my three key takeaways on what
China's reopening means for the world
economy
[Music]
China's economy suffered during the zero
covert policy and that was probably one
reason why the policy was increasingly
untenable for China's leadership some
economists think that by the first
quarter of 2024 China's GDP might be 10
percent bigger than it is expected to be
in the first three months of this year
outside of China reopening will have
positive and negative effects one thing
to look at is tourism
for countries that rely heavily on
Chinese tourism reopening will be very
welcome news tourists will start to go
out and about again and for a place like
Hong Kong that will mean a big boost to
GDP economists think it might Rise by
about eight percent once China fully
reopens although countries in the west
are starting to place travel
restrictions on Chinese tourists that
won't affect their economies as much as
they're less reliant on Chinese tourist
spending but what will affect the West
is another unfortunate side effect of
China reopening
China is a big consumer of the world's
Commodities it buys about a fifth of the
world's oil and three-fifths of the
world's iron all and as China starts to
grow faster it starts to demand more of
those Commodities which pushes up the
global price oil for example Goldman
Sachs a bank thinks that full Chinese
reopening might lead to prices rising by
about a quarter compared with today's
prices up to a hundred dollars a barrel
now that's not as bad as it was during
the spike soon after Russia invaded
Ukraine but it's still an extra
complication as central banks try to
fight inflation
there's an extra complication for Europe
which is trying to wean itself off
Russian natural gas that's meant relying
more on imported liquefied natural gas
and if China recovers very strongly it
might start to demand more LNG as well
that'll make it harder for Europe to
secure the supplies that it needs and
according to some forecasters in a
scenario where winter starts punctually
at the end of this year Europe might
find itself having to introduce
rationing
the Draconian implementation of
zerocovid and then the chaotic reopening
has had the effect of putting some
foreign companies off the idea of
relying so much on China for their
production some have started to shift
their operations elsewhere According to
some measures foreign investment into
new factories in China have fallen Apple
for example has shifted some of its
production out of China to Vietnam and
India partly because of some of the
chaos of operating during the final days
of the zero covered policy so perhaps
one of the big questions after China is
fully reopened is how quickly that trust
is won back and whether China manages to
woo foreign investors and business
people back again
watching to read more of our content on
China's reopening click on the link and
please don't forget to subscribe
[Music]